[Music]
thanks
thank you um good morning my name is
allah and
i would like to talk to you today about
publishing on the web
so imagine publishing on the web rights
when the web was born
so a web page would look something like
this you would have titles
links sidebar a search functionality and
all of this
you would like to have on every page um
it's quite easy to rewrite it all the
time so this is why we have content
management systems right um they
simplify
web publishing quite a lot
so uh titles menus breadcrumbs they're
all generated for you
and when wordpress was born 16 years ago
um out of this desire to simplify
publishing on the web
they also added a function called autop
because i still need to rewrite every
single paragraph tag in this content
but i just
sorry so i would add it
so i would it automatically wrap every
line of uh text
separated by two line breaks with
paragraph text
this was before any visual editors
existed on the web
um it was even before markdown was born
and i see this a bit as the first step
towards visual editing
so this simplifies web publishing a
little bit
but you would still have to write other
html like
links images order formatting
so it's still not easy to read this text
and it still looks a bit like called
a year later a visual editor called
steinmc was born
and wordpress included it into the cms
and it would like would look like this
and everything was well
at least for a while
so how did this visual editor work well
it used the browser api called
content editable it's really cool you
can
just add this attribute to any html tag
and it would make everything editable
inside it
you can even put it on the body elements
and your whole page
becomes editable
you can literally put anything inside it
it's really magic
but this api had no specification
it was just something internet explorer
5.5 included
and it was later taken over by other
browsers
every browser implemented it a bit
differently
so everyone had their own opinions about
how it should work
should enter create a paragraph like or
a line break tag should it create a div
tag
should it depend on the context screen
should backspace
delete a selected image or should it
delete the entire
uh figure check what should happen with
the caption
um what happens if you press the ball
command should browser
insert inline styles should it create a
btec or a strong tag
another problem is that any visual
representation of your content
has an infinite amount of dom forms so
there can be invisible spandex
invisible characters like non-breaking
spaces
nested elements you can even split a tag
into multiple pieces and you wouldn't
see it
so you literally don't see what you're
doing and this dom content
becomes your source of truth
so selection has the same problem
let me quickly show you so if i select
this text
did i select a paragraph contents or did
i select a whole paragraph
or did i select the entire blog watch
the visual representation is very
ambiguous
and here we have a link um if you have
an insertion point
you cannot really tell if the insertion
point is inside or outside a link
you have no choice where to insert
and finally um when you have
non-editable areas inside editable areas
uh it's very buggy across browsers as
well and this is an essential building
zone for more complex editors
so i think we can agree that's consonant
that spells a bit of black magic
um you can put anything inside it
and you don't know what will happen it's
a bit of a black box
and what will come out is html soup
so we don't want to build an editor onto
such complex foundations
slowly writing on the web became more
chaotic
and content editable was not the only
thing to blame
the wordpress editor also had some
design problems
brief plugins would try to build things
on continental and tiny mc
other plugins would create shortcuts for
more complex things
so this would create even more chords
and even more ever presents
some plugins would even give up on the
visual editor entirely
and put custom boxes outside the editor
they would do it all differently so
different colored buttons
different size models each more bigger
and bigger to grab your attention
so i would call this spaghetti ui
it's a bit like spaghetti called button
in the ui
and in comes gutenberg
it took us quite a while to build as
because we had to take all these plugins
into consideration
with gutenberg we wanted to create an
editor from the ground up
we wanted publishing on the web to
become effortless and we wanted to end
the content editable mess
we also wanted to create consistency in
the ui
this was also an opportunity for
wordpress to
introduce javascript more seriously into
the community
so how did we do this everything becomes
a block
so paragraphs images headings
embeds and this might sound a bit simple
but it's important to think about a
writing experience as something fluids
so it's not immediately obvious in terms
of ui and in terms of
in terms of an extension mechanism
it is in html though html has block
level elements and we would like this
underlying structure to shine through
so first let's have a look at how we
save this content
even though the editor state is an
object tree a tree of blocks
we don't want to save it as json or
short calls or some custom markup
we still want to save it as html saving
as html ensures that the data is
portable
it works everywhere and we don't want
the user to be locked into our system
also html is a bit of the also it
doesn't need any logic to render the
page so
if a plugin disappears the content will
still be there the ph can still render
html is quite a bit of a lower language
of the web
but we need a markup to carry more
meaning
think about a table for example
it can be used for well a plain table
and a plain table block or a calendar
block
so we decided to use html comments to
describe and to separate these blocks
they are syntactically very different
from html
so our blog parser doesn't need to know
html
and outside of this block edit context
these commands will just disappear
it also makes it possible to have well
here you see
an example of a of a block a calendar
block
and it also makes it possible to create
dynamic blocks so blocks that rely on
some external data to render like
advertisement or photo album
wordpress really values backwards
compatibility
and we want to respect existing content
so content outside of these block
delimiters are put in a sort of fallback
block
um and a file back block is actually the
entire old editor
inside a block if you do not wish to
need
to use a new editor or you just want to
keep on writing in html it's possible
you can just
use this small block this shows how
robust
the block system is each block
is an isolated container
the block parser can recover from any
invalid html because it doesn't need to
parse it
html parsing errors are isolated on the
block level
the same for javascript errors so we use
react
error boundaries to catch the errors and
to display them inside the blocks
so if any plugin creates an error it's
no problem for the entire editor
and finally since we don't use
continental on the entire
on the entire block list we don't have
to worry about a blog about browser
messing the
markup up
so now some new things about the editor
um we have placeholders
so if you're writing a text you can just
insert the image placeholders keep on
writing
and fill in the blanks later
um also together these placeholders can
form templates so
if a user doesn't really know how to
create a more complex layout
they can rely on templates created by
themes or plugins to insert one and then
also fill in the blanks
for example here that's an example from
amnesty international
if you would like to reuse a piece of
content
you can make a block reusable and use it
on every page
every other page so any update
update to this block will reflect on all
other pages
so in the background this is actually a
dynamic block
um so the editor is quite simple to
extend people have created drawing
blocks form blocks
uh you can even put a whole code editor
inside the editor
and here you can see it's like a blog
that someone created in 137 lines of
javascript
finally it's much easier to discover
features
before people wouldn't know how to paste
the youtube url
that passing a youtube url would
automatically embed the video
now this youtube block is part of the
blog list so it's
it's easier to discover and it's also
searchable
uh in the future we'd like to hook this
up on the plugin directory
and so if you search for a block and
it's not installed locally you will get
some suggestions to install
plugins and you can install it right in
the editor
this is to eliminate some dead ends in
the user experience
now what about rich text we still want
to write inside this box right
so to quickly kickstart development we
put tinymc inside a rich text component
inside react
but we knew that eventually we wanted
something more something lighter and
something more integrated
so because we had like react ui and it
didn't need to handle things like ps and
block level interactions
and on top of that we also wanted some
custom features
for example uh format boundaries
so here you can see that you have a link
and with a
with a left and right arrow keys you can
navigate inside and outside of a link
so this makes it easier if you want to
search on the inside or outside
and you can try this in any other editor
it's not really possible try it in
google docs for example
so we decided to you to build our own
rich text
components and guess what to use for
that
content as well content editable just
gives you a lot of stuff for free
it just works in other languages like
arabic japanese
out of the box it's accessible it
resizes
and native ui just works for example
if you shake your phone to undo what
you've written
or if you want to use the formatting
buttons on a touch bar of a macbook
so content editable is actually quite
good at text level editing
just not at anything else so our
components
so in our components we want to control
the state and we separated
text and formats
this makes it much easier to manipulate
the data
instead of having a tree of formatting
elements
you have all the normal string string
methods you can use
and you also have some some extra
formatting related
functions
so how does this work well for example
if you have an editor
you have a universal keys like enter
delete arrow keys
so we create a new object from the
previous old object
with the helper functions and then
updated on with the diffing algorithm
pretty much like react works but for
inputs
we have to look at a dom create an
object
take the content out of there that we
need and then again update it on
we can sync it if the browser does
anything strange in there
the richtex component is also extensible
so
it's possible to run content through
transformations on input
for example here you can see if you type
backtick
text back it can automatically transform
to a
quote tag
it's also possible to add custom feed
custom formats
things like autocomplete annotations you
can even do content checking like
analysis or spell checking
and it's much easier to implement
because the state is separated from the
dom
finally the blocks are tied together the
blocks and rich checks are tied together
with
explicit interactions this is to ensure
a good writing flow
so if you want to split the blocks you
can still use enter if you want to merge
you can use delete
because it shouldn't feel too blocky
right
the difference is that these blocks
interactions are
done by us not by the browser
so this editor we build is super
versatile you can use it for documents
static pages there's even people using
the editor to create amp stories
other cmss are also adopting it like
drupal
and actually i've made this whole
slideshow in
gutenberg as well so i'll quickly show
you and exit the page
edit presentation
so here you can see that every slide is
a block and there's blocks
inside those slides so headings
paragraphs
you can also add things like let me
like images upload an image
you can resize it you can move it
you can easily move it around so you
don't have to copy paste
and you can also we have some rich so
rich text and extensions work for
example
if i want to make something appear on
the next
keystroke for my slides i can create a
slide fragment
let's now go back to the presentation
so you can make slides with it and we're
actually also
using this editor now to edit the full
site
so editing themes is actually how i got
involved how i got involved into
wordpress and how i learned php and
javascript
but not everyone has the time or the
patience or interest to do that right
this is very simplified but um
a theme templates a wordpress theme
template would look something like this
you have some php and some
html tags but why not let
the user directly manipulate those
blocks
with a graphic user interface why not
let the user edit the whole site
why should it be reserved for people who
know html or for people who want to code
this gives more power to the user and
the theme is reduced to a stylesheet
in fact it gets rid of php entirely for
for the templates
for templating
[Applause]
so there's a reason we called it
gutenberg and just like
gutenberg's printing press changed how
book book publishing works we're hoping
that
this editor changes how apple publishing
works
we want web publishing um on the web
to become accessible to everyone we want
you to be able to break out of all
gardens of the internet we want you to
be able to
publish on your own server and to own
your data
and i hope this project can help
decentralize the web a bit again
wordpress is also translated in over 100
languages
and you can add your own it has 38
million active installs
and these 38 million active installs
are separate servers so they're not
owned by one company
so if you have questions i'll be around
later and
i'm on twitter at electrics without i i
also work for automatic so if you're
interested in all these
things feel free to apply and work with
us
and yeah thanks for coming and thanks
jsconfu for having me
[Music]
you